[Aplausos]
[Música]
sebastián piñera ya es presidente bueno
mejor dicho vuelve a ser presidente
porque como todos sabéis este líder
político ya fue presidente de chile hace
escasamente dos legislaturas entre 2010
y 2014
[Música]
hoy ha sido un gran día para chile ahora
tras conseguir una importante y abultada
victoria por casi 10 puntos en las
pasadas elecciones presidenciales de
2017 el día 11 de marzo sebastián piñera
fue investido presidente
[Música]
por qué
pues bien amigos en este vídeo vamos a
ver qué chile hereda este presidente y
también cuáles son los grandes retos que
tiene por delante pero antes de nada
conozcamos un poquito mejor al nuevo
presidente veamos quién es sebastián
piñera
[Música]
tienes sebastián piñera
amigos lo primero que tenemos que tener
claro es que sebastián piñera por muchos
motivos no es un político más no es un
político cualquiera fijaos hablamos de
un personaje que por un lado es dueño de
una de las mayores fortunas de chile una
fortuna amigos que la revista forbes
estima ni más ni menos atentos que en
2.700 millones de dólares tal cual como
lo escucháis yo siempre me he rebelado
contra aquellos que quieren apartar del
gobierno el espíritu emprendedor me
parece tan absurdo que prefieran un
gobierno lleno de operadores políticos y
vacío de emprendedores honestos que los
primeros puedan postular a todos los
segundos a nada
[Música]
sebastián piñera fue durante años un
agresivo hombre de negocios hecho a sí
mismo y es que no os dejéis engañar por
su sonrisa profident su historial nos
demuestra que durante mucho tiempo
sebastián piñera supo jugar al límite y
convertirse en un importante inversor en
sectores tan distintos como la
construcción los supermercados las
líneas aéreas o los canales de
televisión si ahora que lo pienso es
difícil dar con un sector en el que
piñera no haya probado suerte incluso en
2006 decidió apostar por la industria
del fútbol y se hizo con el control de
un equipo pero no de un equipo
cualquiera sino del equipo más
importante del país el colo colo claro
que muchos críticos le acusan de comprar
este equipo no como inversión sino sobre
todo como trampolín político a los
silvio berlusconi pero no penséis que
las hazañas de piñera se quedan sólo en
el terreno empresarial para nada
en el terreno político el actual
presidente de chile también ha dejado
huella sobre todo cuando tenemos en
cuenta que en el año 2010 se convirtió
en el primer presidente de un partido de
derechas elegido democráticamente ni más
ni menos que desde 1958 si así es
sebastián piñera ha sido el primer
político de derechas en ganar unas
elecciones desde que se produjera la
transición democrática tras la etapa de
augusto pinochet
y ahora en 2018 vuelve a repetir
en otras palabras creo que bien podemos
decir que sebastián piñera es un tipo
con fortuna nos parece pues bien el caso
es que a pesar de tener que enfrentarse
con las consecuencias del terrible
terremoto que en 2010 apenas dos semanas
antes de su investidura sacudió el país
su primer gobierno tuvo unos resultados
relativamente buenos al menos la mitad
del esfuerzo durante toda la gestión fue
dedicado a la reconstrucción del país y
en consecuencia se sacrificaron muchas
cosas que hubiéramos querido hacer
rodrigo hinspeter ministro de interior y
ministro de defensa en el primer
gobierno de sebastián piñera es verdad
que no se produjo ningún gran cambio
revolucionario pero en sus cuatro años
de gobierno el crecimiento económico
superó el 5 por ciento anual se crearon
más de un millón de empleos los salarios
aumentaron y la pobreza se redujo con
fuerzas tuvimos un muy buen gobierno en
el que todos los indicadores sociales y
económicos mejoraron en chile- pero
tengo más experiencia ahora y la
experiencia cuenta sebastián piñera y lo
cierto amigos es que
la ocasión toda esta experiencia puede
ser muy pero que muy importante porque
pues porque el chile de hoy es bastante
diferente atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el chile de hoy
os lo hemos contado aquí en visual
político y desde luego no creo que sea
algo que sorprenda a nadie durante las
últimas décadas chile ha sido algo así
como el cristiano ronaldo de américa
latina' el país que más crecía el que
más éxitos cosechaba buena prueba de
ello es la evolución que ha tenido la
clase media en este país que se ha
multiplicado prácticamente por tres en
muy poco tiempo la clase media en chile
creció desde el 23 7% al 64,3 de la
población en 25 años sin embargo amigos
tal y como vimos aquí en un pasado vídeo
cuyo enlace os dejo en la descripción en
los últimos años concretamente durante
la última legislatura de michelle
bachelet las cosas han cambiado chile es
un país mediano que aún no alcanza el
pleno desarrollo pero su acelerada
modernización de las últimas décadas nos
ha puesto de lleno en la frontera de los
desafíos de la modernidad y en las
tensiones que enfrentan la democracia y
el crecimiento económico
en los últimos años el crecimiento
económico se ha desplomado la creación
de empleos se ha frenado los salarios no
crecen y la inversión extranjera se ha
desplomado en los últimos años lo único
que ha crecido en chile han sido los
empleados públicos los impuestos y la
burocracia
[Música]
así es prácticamente todos los
parámetros económicos han tenido una
evolución muy pero que muy negativa
durante la última legislatura de
michelle bachelet fijaos por ejemplo el
crecimiento promedio apenas ha sido del
18 por ciento anual lo que implica que
esta legislatura haya sido la peor la
peor en términos de crecimiento
económico desde la transición
democrática
[Aplausos]
de hecho durante los últimos años sigue
ha crecido menos que la economía mundial
y bastante menos que sus compañeros de
la alianza del pacífico méxico perú y
colombia- y eso no es todo el déficit
público ha pasado de invitado a
inquilino permanente y claro eso tiene
consecuencias por ejemplo la deuda
pública aunque sigue siendo baja ha
alcanzado su mayor nivel desde 1993
no es sostenible que la deuda fiscal se
doble cada cuatro años ese es el camino
del despeñadero felipe larraín ministro
de hacienda aunque lo peor con
diferencia ha sido la caída de la
inversión durante cuatro años
consecutivos y ojo no ha sido solo la
economía lo que ha ido mal para nada las
tasas de delincuencia y criminalidad han
aumentado con fuerza en la región de la
araucanía donde existe un conflicto con
los pueblos indígenas los mapuches que
reclaman más autonomía y reconocimiento
los actos violentos se han disparado han
crecido un 150 por ciento
qué pretende el gobierno que los
ciudadanos tengan que organizar milicias
armadas para protegerse o que deben
tomar la justicia por sus propias manos
e incluso en materia de salud la
decisión del gobierno de suspender el
sistema de concesión de hospitales ha
hecho que el gobierno apenas haya podido
invertir poco más de la mitad de las
inversiones presupuestadas haciendo de
las listas de espera y los problemas en
la calidad un mal crónico
y no nos engañemos los más perjudicados
por todos estos resultados no son los
más ricos sino las clases medias y sobre
todo la población más vulnerable los más
pobres vamos que en otras palabras
amigos creo que podemos decir que los
chilenos no tienen muchos motivos para
celebrar el último mandato de michelle
bachelet menudos cuatro años tal vez la
mejor forma de ver lo que está
ocurriendo en chile es echar un vistazo
al índice de libertad económica cuya
correlación con el nivel de riqueza y
prosperidad de un país es altísima pues
bien durante el último mandato de
michelle bachelet chile se ha desplomado
ha pasado del puesto 7 al puesto 20
y no para los malpensados aquí no
hablamos de cambios metodológicos en fin
amigos este es el chile al que se tiene
que enfrentar el nuevo presidente
sebastián piñera ahora la pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es cuáles deben ser
las prioridades del nuevo gobierno que
podemos esperar bien veámoslo
tenemos que acercar el estado a los
ciudadanos
ojo va a ser bueno un gobierno que tiene
aquí destacado que no tiene subido en la
frustración que no crea sino que
destruye los buenos empleos que nombré
fueron los salarios y las pensiones
[Música]
los grandes retos bueno parece claro que
con semejante evolución y en un país que
sin ser precisamente barato tres de cada
cuatro trabajadores ganan menos de 800
dólares al mes la economía tiene que ser
la prioridad número uno si la economía
no va bien las estadísticas sociales
tampoco van a marchar bien y esto es
algo que parece que el nuevo gobierno
tiene muy pero que muy claro
el nuevo presidente ha prometido que
centrará sus esfuerzos en duplicar el
crecimiento económico crear cientos de
empleos y sentar las bases para que
chile se convierta como muy tarde en
2025 en el primer país desarrollado de
américa latina'
pero vale estoy seguro que estáis
pensando bien pero cómo lograrlo
espero que no se deje entusiasmar con la
idea de que sólo con una reforma
tributaria o solo dando más seguridad
sobre la dirección de reformas como la
laboral será suficiente para restablecer
el crecimiento en chile- va a necesitar
una política agresiva para estimular la
diversificación casi la mitad de las
exportaciones del país siguen siendo
cobre ricardo hausmann pues amigos para
conseguir el objetivo en el año 2025 el
país tiene que asumir tres prioridades
muy claras diversificar su economía
mejorar la productividad y ajustar las
cuentas públicas y no no penséis que
todo esto es un trabajo precisamente
fácil para diversificar la economía
dejar de depender tanto de las materias
primas especialmente del cobre e
impulsar la productividad y el chile de
piñera va a necesitar unas cuantas cosas
primero promover la inversión
especialmente la inversión extranjera es
decir lograr atraer más empresas y
capitales extranjeros que apuesten por
chile' para producir y prestar servicios
algo para lo que vendría muy bien
dar marcha atrás a la pésima reforma
tributaria de bachelet que precisamente
castigó la inversión que idea más mala y
también reducir la enorme burocracia
por ejemplo digitalizando todos los
procesos segundo y este es un tema mucho
más controvertido promover un programa
de atracción de talento extranjero si
promover la inmigración
veréis en chile- la población inmigrante
ha crecido mucho en los últimos años
pero aún sigue siendo muy baja no llega
al 3% de la población y amigos a los
chilenos les gusta compararse con
australia o nueva zelanda pues bien en
estos países la población inmigrante se
acerca casi al 30% del total 10 veces
más que en chile
si amigos lo hemos contado aquí la mejor
forma de hacerse con talento y promover
negocios y actividades diferentes es
lograr atraer a personas con diferentes
competencias y capacidades del resto del
mundo
hablaremos muy pronto con más detalle de
todo esto pero sólo un dato en sillicon
valley el gran centro de la innovación
mundial por ejemplo el 54% de los
emprendedores más de la mitad son
extranjeros
y no no se trata de hablar de barra
libre sino de poner en marcha mecanismos
que clarifiquen impulsen la atracción de
talento al fin y al cabo si las cosas se
hacen bien si le puede aspirar a
convertirse en la gran referencia para
los negocios de toda américa latina y
eso implica necesariamente atraer
profesionales
además según las estadísticas
disponibles los inmigrantes tienen de
media más estudios su participación
laboral es mucho mayor y ganan más
dinero luego también hay que mejorar las
relaciones entre la universidad y la
empresa combatir las tasas de
inseguridad acabar con el déficit
público mejorar las infraestructuras e
incrementar el ahorro todas estas son
políticas que chile necesita para
despegar
pues bien si echamos un vistazo al
programa de sebastián piñera veremos que
las promesas del presidente discurren en
esta línea así que en principio a priori
todo apunta a que el cambio político en
chile va a ser bueno para el país claro
que como todos sabemos sólo el tiempo
podrá darnos una respuesta definitiva
pero un momento porque no todo será tan
sencillo
debido a la reforma de la ley electoral
que impulsó michelle bachelet la
coalición de piñera no tiene mayoría en
el congreso
así que negociar y buscar acuerdos
parlamentarios será toda una prioridad
para este nuevo equipo de gobierno en
fin amigos así están las cosas pero
ahora turno para ti qué opinión tienes
del nuevo gobierno de sebastián piñera
cómo crees que será su gobierno para
chile déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
no olvides darle a like y compartirlo
con tus amigos un saludo y hasta la
próxima
tenemos que acercar el estado a mi
ciudad
como va a ser bueno un gobierno que
tiene a ti destacado que no tiene
asumido las frustraciones que no crea
sino que destruye los buenos empleos que
no mejoran los salarios de la atención